Okay, so now we have the lay out for
our activities as designed, and
our manifest and
grader files are set up.
So the next thing to do
is to write the code.
If you haven't done so already,
open up the main activity and
at the top you'll see there
are a number of imports.
We have to add a few more.
Let's take a look at what they'll be,
I'll just paste them in.
So you can see here, these are the
imports that we're going to be using.
Things such as the login utility,
the text View control that
we've seen earlier on.
A location object that we're using for
determining location details, and
then all this stuff that's going to
be used by the location services;
connection results, API client,
connection call backs,
the on connection failed listener.
And of course the location
services themselves.
So these provide all the classes
that we're going to be using, and
next we're going to edit
main activity code itself.
We can see that the basic one that we
have just extends action bar activity,
but we need a few more interfaces.